تيك توك ما زال عالقا في صراع جيوسياسي
بين واشنطن وبكين وظهر الرئيس التنفيذي
لشركه تيك توك
شوتشيو امام لجنه في مجلس النواب الامريكي
لاقناعهم بالتراجع عن مخططاتهم لحظر
التطبيق بالكامل في الولايات المتحده او
اجبار تيك توك على الانفصال عن الشركه
الام باي دانس
المسؤول الصيني واجه وابل من الاسئله من
الممثلين في اللجنه حول سياسات حمايه
البيانات وما اذا كانت ملكيه التطبيق من
قبل شركه تكنولوجيا صينيه تشكل خطرا على
الامن القومي الامريكي تشو يدخل عش
الدبابير بقدميه قريبا لكن لديه خطه
لتفادي اللدغات خلال شهادته الاولى امام
الكونجرس سلطت شو الضوء على ارشادات
السلامه الجديده لتيك توك لابعاد الانظار
عن اي ضغوط امريكيه بهدف اجبار المنصه على
تسليم خوارزميتها
وستتضمن جهود تيك توك منع المستخدمين تحت
سن السادسه عشره من ارسال رسائل مباشره
وذلك لحمايه المراهقين بالاضافه الى تكثيف
اجراءات لازاله المحتوى العنيف من المنصه
وتركز محاولات تشو لطمانه الامريكيين على
مشروع تكساس ايضا الذي يمثل وعدا بحمايه
بيانات المستخدمين الامريكيين عبر حفظ
بياناتهم في شركات محليه مثل اوراكل
ولكن مع كل هذه الجهود يبدو ان الولايات
المتحده ستظل دائما قلقه طالما تحتفظ بكين
بسيطرتها على تيك توك
ومن ناحيه اخرى يرى الخبراء ان الصين تفضل
خروج تيك توك من السوق الامريكي بدلا من
بيعها للولايات المتحده